to work at the puddle carwash in Boulder
those guys
somebody at that University was just
robbing those gloves by the box I must
have had 20 of those pairs of boxes at
the glove not boxes I'm sorry 20 of
those drugs never liked those black yeah
that the receivers even buy yes it would
be at the carwash Worley and the [ __ ]
people from the universe become dango
why does everybody
did we painting University of Denver all
over the [ __ ] no Boulder Boulder heads
was so bold I had him and they had him
like in-home colors I think like black
and gold out of like if they saw you
would like the gold ones people general
into you with the gold but in those days
that's how those students it's how those
football players made a living yeah they
stole [ __ ] and sold the memorabilia
statue are you using them for at the car
wash though what do you mean well I
gotta give your hand you guys keep your
hands dry Drive so you would like that
down and then just to be cool if he was
painted like me I was a [ __ ] salesman
to call I know yeah look I had dried
windows for about a week visiting and
that was it has a horrible job yeah
horrible well I got that job like
November 28th and I kept that job to
like [ __ ] January 10th and then right
before the Superbowl
I got in doing that a detail body shop
but I was at the puddle out there
thought I'd call - I had a license and
they wouldn't let me drive like there
was a kid they paid just to dry pull the
cars out put him in the spot right and
it was mr. cool we had that yeah a hat
like everybody know who he was yeah I
got him off pieces here Ted uh [ __ ] I
would steal tips
anybody who gave me money I belong to me
[ __ ] if I saw you out there with two
bucks in a ticket I'd work my angle so I
was right there oh thank you sometimes I
put a dollar in sometimes I keep a
dollar you know you know it was always
an angle that was a sad thing that was
always everybody was [ __ ] stealing
that's yes sir that place must have made
millions of dollars because when I was a
kid and I worked
I found that [ __ ] that everybody was
robbing that play it's amazing go there
nor washes are a really great business
to just make money
oh it's a cash business a cash cow my
friends had one in Hoboken when I was
growing up it's a cash cow you know if
you get it the salesman is the whole
thing really that guy at the window when
you see the ones around here those guys
why would you hire these Mexican dudes
if they can't which one do you want yeah
give me the regular we do you know what
the 1695 dog I would work you to Pete
four pieces for extra bucks you get no
more tires no I'm looking at the car
wash it I'm the basic car washes this
[ __ ] it's 695 I'm gonna charge you 695 a
basic car wash but I'm also going to do
this I'm gonna waxing I'm not gonna
airbrush inhibitor which was nothing
less than heaven is like [ __ ] what a
spread it yeah under the collar to
shield it against soft and rock yeah I'm
gonna spray stuff on your rims I'm there
are more than enough nice I'm gonna try
you know how would work that let me
throw in this let me throw in that
because you figured out what cost
nothing what costs nothing you know I
went to the ball something let me answer
was what can I throw in here and make
you know no I didn't even know that's
gonna be there too stupid yeah they're
still going there's still work in the
seventies Adam Sean Joey Diaz stop you
know saying Joey Diaz Styles taking it
from a different perspective you know
when you sell causes when you sell cars
and Denver Colorado you go for gross
what is gross the amount over the
invoice you know the sticker says 20,000
we own the cost for 17 5 I make a living
off me making you believe that that
cause with $20,000 if I sell you that
car correctly you're going to get for a
little discount just to let your friends
know but if I sell that car correctly to
you and and if I show you the lighters
and I take an hour with the bell but if
it's blinker this is worth 2,000 right
here I'm saying when you sell the car
with value you could make grouse in New
York it's such a hard town when I worked
I didn't work for the potemkin to the
parameters of the thief in New York City
but everybody's little yeah the Potemkin
is you know about the Daily News yep
Potemkin oh I got a Cadillac special
$1.99 $1.99 a month wait till you get
there you leave there with 300 a month
and a [ __ ] beat in the black eye you
would have for 18 hours your mother
bought a car that use your son social
they don't give a [ __ ] over there poked
apple at least that was how it was 20
years ago that's what you went to work
the up when you wanted to make money and
not have a soul there was a lot of those
places
Douglas Toyota when I worked at Douglas
Taylor listen 87 88 90 91 they were
cells making 12 grand a month these guys
will make any bugs around people like 12
grand a month Joey I make that selling
[ __ ] yet listen these guys will be
robbing people or making 8 bucks an hour
yeah they're making 12,000 a month now
those guys had no conscience
they actually did that then they give
you to a closer that's the place to sell
Douglas it's known what I know now I bet
anybody who's 21 call me go to Douglas
if it's still line a closer would you
just get them wet and yell responsibly
how you don't Steve what's happening
boom or what are you looking again I'll
tell you what a salad jointless ones do
let me ask you points are we gonna buy a
car you shot well a thermometer with
what put you in a car are you concerned
cut the damn gonna work Harvey I'm gonna
fight this [ __ ] this guy here this is
Trump's nephew
yes I'm gonna go on and hit him with a
stick no protesting no dunno about you
thinking for the ride you bringing back
mama in New York you don't make money
from that you make money from
accessories and financing oh the up
packages and stuffs of the rims the
[ __ ] the state laws that come out on
the side yeah get into alarms that thing
all the sidelines in the TVs in the bad
give you a taste of financing in New
York yeah and a lot of you want the
whole package that I want you to sell
financing from the jump we all know it
pay for this visa
credit union West already you credit you
know be sure we weren't gonna hide your
bags if you're kinda salad
I don't 100 people but you work without
hundred back 100 man I put one [ __ ]
button in now and it's like utopia it's
like if you want to hook it and you
press a button now yeah 22 [ __ ] hook
it's a pop up on your computer same
thing I got a hundred [ __ ] banks and
you tell them to give you your ring
you're gonna lie and I'm gonna lie
you're gonna say it's 9:00 but universe
I am 98.9 I'll beat it well if I got you
eight today right now with the low
downpayment let you keep a thousand use
it for your son's [ __ ] football team
give it to the money for the show you
know a little bit early [ __ ] when I was
a [ __ ] in getting not only pleasure
that didn't it's yeah it's a nun nun
[ __ ] scene I made money office up I
started doing that [ __ ] so how did Dan
so how do you make money if you're the
before the closer like if you have to
they have to sell the car or you just
getting paid for doing that okay the
closer for the closer to come in you
have to get a commitment okay what's
your commitment I'm gonna buy this car I
just yes I want to do 300 a month no I
really didn't say I want and so few
seventies whatever I want to you but I'm
thousand all I got to do is this I gotta
get you the downpayment you want the
price on your trade that you want oh my
god you gave me that and then we'll get
this five and eight oh and then he'll
have you sign all four boxes I got a
credit card from you and I bring it to a
close I wish this [ __ ] animal luck
and I second to a guy we've been beating
women for the last 30 years of his life
to divorce yes eight divorces he's
eighth in a softball team yeah six
rehabs robbed one of them at gunpoint
this guy comes in and just torment you
to death before
I mean and then he brings you to leave
the gas into a package so I got a gas in
your packet and then he brings it a
chick that does the whole introduction
to the cost you already sold another car
you're smoking by the time that guy goes
to F and I and then to the pub they
called it in those days they had girls
hot girls that we show you everything
about you Kong explain the lease or the
payment plan who you paint it - yeah I
don't have that anymore yes they do on
vlogging in Panorama City well because
it's very to when you have that last
customer service rep they make sure that
you listen tasks like these dealers are
they make sure that when you get your
customer rating you bring it back to
them and let them fill it out and I not
only by your tank again
but I also drove over India my tank
because that's the most important thing
the customer service index is the most
important thing and the most important
thing to white people because white you
have to go on there and they see your
customer service and next down and I do
business with you
wait this you know not before yeah this
is before yeah it was almost like what
was that service business consumer yeah
this is way up no no no no and they
still got it now when you buy a car
dealer will send you a [ __ ] thing
mm-hmm because that's cool lets you know
how whether you get certain cars
if you treat your customers shitty they
ain't gonna send you all the garages
yeah they're gonna give you a shitty
special allotment of cars are gonna send
your red cars and arrancars convertible
so I'm green won the war and nobody
[ __ ] wants so that's that you have to
have a high customer rating now man you
really do it's got to be like
extraordinary when I do some business
with this Subaru they go above and
beyond that's why I've gotten four cars
from them I'm on my fourth or fifth six
cars from the valley right there yeah
nine eyes I'm Bruce he comes to my shows
he calls you know that's why I just call
them coming up when Thursday at 3b they
are ready for me but they're boom I walk
in no down payment because I just go
from least at least Philly's yeah I'm
American dog well I started when I sew
cause I learn more about life than
anything ever you know when you there's
certain companies you work with that you
tell me I'm gonna pay this downpayment
one time but I'm gonna get one of these
every three years
yeah I'm just confident I'm gonna call
you at 1:00 I'm gonna pick the car
before it's wash this fully guess I sign
for papers that's what I've seen three
years after a while they'll know you
just tell them yeah how I want to do
business
listen whatever and they'll your
having customer you're always going to
hell these from the movie [ __ ] in three
years you're going to go to the service
department you don't have you're gonna
work it they work with you bro
I've always bought car I've never least
a no no no no no more that ends that
ends now